اتمنى ان لا تسالوني عنه مره اخرى جسمي
يقشعر عندما اسمع اسمه لن نرجع لبعضنا فهو
خائن ولا مجال للتفكير
لهذه الكلمات اغلى مقطع فيديو انتشر عبر
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لهبه ابوك زوجه
نجم المنتخب المغربي ونادي باريس سان
جيرمان اشرف حكيمي بعد تهمته بالاغتصاب
التي وجهت اليه قبل ايام فقد انتشر
الفيديو كالناري في الهجيم وقيل انه
للممثله الاسبانيه خلال مقابله صحفيه حتى
انه كان باللغه الاسبانيه مع ترجمه اسفل
الشاشه
وما ان تم تداول المقطع حتى قال البعض انه
يؤكد كل الاخبار السابقه التي انتشرت
مؤخرا حول نيه هبه للطلاق وبداها فعلا
بالاجراءات دون اي تاكيدات رسميه او
تصريحات منها او من فريقها القانوني
الا ان المفارقه تكمن بان الفيديو مغلوط
تماما وكلما جاء في ترجمته عار عن الصحه
فالمقابله اجريت في فبراير الماضي اي قبل
اتهامه بالاغتصاب وتتحدث فيه يعبوك عن
اولادها لا عن زوجها قائله انهما مختلفان
كاختلاف الليل والنهار جسديا ايضا وواحد
منهم بملامح تدل على اصله والاخر اشقر كما
انها لم تذكر اي شيء عن علاقتها باشرف
حكيمي خلال المقطع المتداول ابدا
الى ذلك توارث الممثله الاسبانيه هبه ابوك
عن الانظار عقب التهمه اكتشفت وسائل اعلام
انها تعيش في مكان مجهول بالعاصمه مدريد
بعدما رفضت العوده الى منزلها الكائن في
احدى ضواحي باريس